hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to getting over it with
Bennet Fadi
I am the bucket and I are gonna
acknowledge the fact that there's a
snake there cuz I don't care it's not
ambition it's not ambitions opposite
engines right you're a mission here you
join or then you'll feel bad if you win
so I put this snake in your body for
bread well I feel good if I lose no not
that way
definitely not that way that's not gonna
work no oh man this doesn't like me
nope there we go no oh that's too much
swing swung okay just enough swing swung
oh boy I don't remember
is it a launch across here is it a
launch across here I can't remember I
can't remember what it is I'm wracking
my brain but nothing's coming up I'm
drawing up up to Cardon a spoiled milk
that's the only thing that's in my brain
right now
oh the inner machinations of my mind are
an enigma here we go okay alright so
this is as far as I've come I've never
been able to get up this hill and I
don't think it's something you can take
slowly you kind of just got a wangled
angle it and hope and if you fall I
gotta like push to get to the wood part
let's see my only hope
have you thought about who you are in
this fight of the man in the pot
Diogenes I use hand I use the top of his
hammer
nope I think not where your hand moves
the hammer may not follow nor the man
nor the man's hand in this year is will
his intent the embodied resolved in his
outer sand no no no no no no no no no no
almost had it
oh so close I was right there I was
right there oh I was right there oh I
was right there
come on no I don't want to go in the
hill anymore that's it that's it got a
bite gotta get a bite to it gotta get a
real bite Oh Randall dangle bite ooh
don't waggle my dangle you bite my why
no no no no no no why am i doing that
now what what is happening no no no it's
getting real Wang Li dangly right now I
swear that it creeps the mouse
sensitivity up like an [ __ ] I swear
it new Oh cuz now it's nice and easy no
it's not it is not easy I'm so scared
I'm so scared I'm so scared I can't get
on the bucket [ __ ] criminy I was so
close
[Music]
[ __ ] criminy all right everybody just
gimme give me some just some quiet and
quiet contemplation this is the last
obstacle oh my god oh my god don't [ __ ]
it up you forget the ice cliff the
platform's Church in the rectory the
living room and the factory playground
construction site
the granite rocks in the lakeside you've
lived a hike
there's no way left to go back up in a
moment
I'll shut up but let me say okay well if
I [ __ ] this up then I'm probably just
gonna throw my computer out of the
window and jump off a bridge but I'm not
gonna lie I know this is the end and I'm
very terrified because I have a funny
feeling I will find a way to screw this
up I know this is the end no I know I'm
gonna find a way to [ __ ] it up I know
I'm gonna find a way to [ __ ] it up and
I'm not gonna [ __ ] it up I'm not I'm not
gonna [ __ ] it up because I know I know
beyond all no man I am just so nervous I
am just a bundle of [ __ ] nerves right
now
bundle of nerves cuz I know this is c2
ha see do you see do you see Oh Mike I
need to calm down her I'm gonna lose
everything I will lose everything I've
done this a million times it just looks
different but I've done this before many
many many times before I'm stuck you
that's an excitable excitable man has
got to be so cautious Here I am
oh my god oh my god oh my god I why did
that happen
oh my god why did that happen ie ie fear
fear fear fear fear fear fear fear fear
fear fear fears the only emotion in my
mind fears the only emotion in my mind
oh Jesus
no why no no I'm so scared I am right
here and my nerves are just making me
[ __ ] it all up I've done this so many
times this is so easy yeah no oh my god
what is happening to me I my hand is
shaking so badly I don't know what that
was no see oh my god oh my goodness
gracious I cannot for the life of me I
can't for the life of me calm down I
cannot calm down I am so nervous
no God Oh No
I'm just go my god I need that haha god
I'm just so [ __ ] nervous
I'm so [ __ ] nervous I don't know why
I don't want to [ __ ] it up I don't know
why I don't understand why I don't know
why I'm right here this is the end I
know just generally I've done this a
million times it's the same thing as
I've always seen that same thing a
million times been through this a
million times just nice and relaxed
there we go get stuck a little bit but I
can get out of that come on you okay
[Music]
oh where am I
oh hello hi hello hi oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh I
dedicate this game to you the one who
came this far I give it to you with all
my love oh I still don't like you still
don't like you still don't like you at
all at all
[Music]
I'm going down this road yeah and I
ain't gonna be treated this away
[Music]
[Laughter]
I ain't gonna be treated this way
[Music]
I'm going where that suits my car
where my cauldrons never come I'm going
where the climate suits Michael
I ain't gonna be treated this away
[Music]
going down this road feeling bad
I'm going down this road feeling bad I'm
going down this road feeling
[Music]
ain't gonna be treated this away
Oh No
um clear time one hour 18 minutes that
is not the clear time clear times like
26 hours oh my god I did it welcome to
the top of the mountain if you're alone
you can come inside and say hello
I solemnly swear that I'm not recording
a stream in this and I understand that
though only those who have climbed are
welcome I'm not gonna show you guys it I
will show you me reacting to it if
that's even appropriate but this is oh
[Music]
oh man
this is worth it yeah I can't tell you
guys what it is I can't I will make that
a complete secret but it's worth it it's
very worth it
and there you have it sorry I can't show
you guys what it is you have to climb to
the top yourself and I know there's some
people that have spoiled it but there's
something to the integrity of it like
really it's a weird thing there there
really is something to that so
I did it thank you everybody so much for
watching thank you everybody for being
here I'm so happy that you joined me and
I don't think I'll ever try this again
but I do want to play more difficult
games if you guys know more difficult
games put them in the comments below it
doesn't matter how much rage I have
there is that feeling of satisfaction I
actually am a person that loves to start
over I start over in everything I do
when I'm playing like oxygen not
included I start over all the time with
better strategies I just love starting
over with more knowledge and experience
same game more experience like there's
something magical about that sometimes I
wish I could new game+ the YouTube thing
but man it's just such a such an amazing
thing so thank you everybody so much for
watching thank you for enjoying
alongside me as I raged my way through
the top of the mountain now and as
always we'll see you in the next video
bye
[Music]